angela merkel prend la mesure des des
gares des dégâts qu'elle qualifie de
surréaliste
la chancelière est arrivé ce midi en
rhénanie palatinat tu l'as jour
allemande la plus sinistrée par les
intempéries
elle promis de reconstruire et appelle à
se presser dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui et en
particulier à schult avec la première
ministre pour dire clairement que nous
du côté fédéral voulons naturellement
obtenir une image concrète de cette
situation disons surréaliste effrayant
c'est l'allemagne qui paye le plus lourd
tribut de ces pluies diluviennes qui se
sont abattues en europe de l'ouest 150
ciment à la belgique qu'on dénombre 27
les secours à pied d'oeuvre cherche
encore les disparus chemakh si ma mère
après le choc et la désolation le
difficile travail de reconstruction
reichstadt dans l'ouest de l'allemagne
militaires pompiers et policiers
déblayer les décombres
sans vraiment savoir à quoi s'attendre
nous avons des autoroutes détruites des
ponts effondrés des routes complètement
défoncée jusqu'à ce que la vie a est
apte et dans les environs reprennent
comme avant il faudra peut-être des
années des mois cela prendra
certainement beaucoup de temps nous
n'avons pas encore trouvé d'occupants
dans les véhicules croisons les doigts
jusqu'à présent toutes les personnes ont
pu quitter leur voiture nous espérons
qu'il en sera de même pour les autres
voitures en tête de films on est dans
cette région de l'ouest de l'allemagne
24000 sauveteurs ont été déployés pour
venir en aide aux habitants des
habitants qui attendent anxieusement de
constater l'étendue des dégâts
ce théâtre
j'attends ici avec ma pelle et ma pompe
j'attends que le pont soit ouvert pour
aller voir ce qu'il reste de ma maison
mes enfants ont grandi dans cette maison
mais nous n'avions jamais vécu cela de
telles intempéries une catastrophe du
siècle
nous n'avions jamais vu cela si le coût
matériel est difficilement quantifiable
le bilan humain lui ne cesse de
s'alourdir dans ce qui s'annonce déjà
comme la pire catastrophe naturelle
depuis un demi-siècle outre-rhin en
belgique l'autre pays européen le plus
touché après l'allemagne la solidarité
s'organise autour des sinistrés ça
avance bien on a eu beaucoup
papa plusieurs reprises de l'aide de
bénévoles
à défaut de deux des deux officiels
enfin on n cho trets et c'est bien on a
tout perdu et j'ai encore ap des
économies mais bon pas grand chose
balade tout perdu
malheureusement mais on reste positif et
on n'a que ça à faire et à reconstruire
tout est gagné
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen s'est
rendu dans plusieurs communes touchées
aux côtés du premier ministre belge qui
a décrété une journée de deuil national
mardi
mbuende vu la destruction
l'important c'est la reconstruction nous
serons là sur le long terme et nous
maintiendrons aux côtés des personnes
qui sont affectées dans cette région et
pas seulement dans cette région partout
la décrue a commencé et le niveau des
cours d'eau baisse
permettant aux secours de rechercher
d'éventuelles nouvelles victimes